comptant beaucoup d'apple cette semaine
je vous ai parlé il ya quelques jours
des rumeurs de l'iphone et ce2 iphone
qui pourrait arriver prochainement l
iphone low cost d'ailleurs si vous
l'avez pas vu je vous invite à aller
voir la vidéo smartphones avec des
grandes bord durant aux grandes bordure
en bas ici pas dans kof
ici pas de faille saïdi et on pourra
voir le grand retour en force de tochigi
pour dire déverrouiller je vous ai parlé
également d'une application qui
s'appelle d'abel tech par filmique vous
permet de filmer avec vos caméras en
même temps caméra arrière caméra avant
même temps ça c'est vraiment cool
vous avez donc la partie wild c'est le
capteur principal c'est le fib on vous
devine est restée la caméra de celle
fille ultra wide celle ultra grand-angle
une fois de plus la vidéo est en ligne
vous pouvez aller la voir d'ailleurs
parlant de ça je vous invite à vous
abonner s'est pas déjà comme ça vous
saurez tout sur les petits textes
smartphone du silex taillé à plein de
trucs à raconter justement aujourd'hui
je vous parle d'un smartphone assez
atypique
on part de sa iphone os promax iphone os
pro-éoliens fabricants qui nous vient de
russie qui s'appelle caillard cavia
russie c'est un peu cliché mais c'est
leur nom en tout cas et ils ont fabriqué
un produit vraiment particulier alors je
vous fais un pitch très très très très
très très très rapide caviar c'est une
entreprise russe qui étaient fondés en
2011 qui va customiser des produits pour
les rendre exceptionnel alors des fois
c'est plutôt bien réussi comme le
produit on va parler aujourd'hui le des
fois il ya un côté un peu kitsch rococo
alors ils ont commencé je crois que ça
avec un iphone 4s
ils ont customisé l'iphone 5 en or
l'iphone 5 aces en titane version armes
à feu ça c'est quand même très très
particulier est ce que c'est un concept
russe allez savoir il ya eu l'iphone 6
il ya une apple watch en or
il ya même eu un os qui à 33,10 version
vladimir poutine voilà ça c'est ça
secret story un iphone 11 système
solaire un iphone 11 marilyn monroe un
iphone
11 mike tyson dr paul pro très girly à
1440 euros et nous ont même fabriqué un
galaxy folle de samsung game of thrones
au tarif de 28 mille 100 euros bon déjà
plus galaxie fall est un petit peu cher
là vous montez quasiment trente mille
rond passe quand même dans d'autres
sphères
alors il faut même vous si vous voulez
faire directement votre création sur
mesure à base d'or de type tonnes de
carbone de pierres précieuses de cuir de
diamants timbrée de ce que vous voulez
vous pouvez le faire comme vous voulez
pour ça il faudra par contre passer à la
caisse va coûter extrêmement cher que
vous vous en douterez à moins que vous
soyez un
me roux que vous soyez à magna du
pétrole russe où vous soyez blindés
blindés blindés d'argent qui est le
pognon qui dévalue tous les côtés le
général ce produit ait pas trop de fric
pour vous il va pas trop être fait pour
moi il va être pour des gens qui ont
beaucoup d'argent et surtout qu'ils
aiment ce typologie produits et donc là
nous en proposons tous vraiment super
marrant est super intéressant c'est à
dire d'unir deux univers vous avez d'un
côté l'univers d'apple avec les derniers
produits en date est d'aller produits
plus haut de gamme de niveaux des
smartphones iphone 11 trop iphone
monstre au max comme cette jolie petite
bête que j'ai ici dans ma main et là
tout est au travail sur une autre marque
qui est hyper sexy c'est la marque
d'elon musk c'était cela et c'est sur
leur seiver troque alors je sais pas si
vous avez suivi normalement ça c'est vu
vu et revu
tesla on connaît effectivement pour les
voitures électriques voitures très haut
de gamme électrique et nous sortir une
espèce d'ovni cider trucks un espèce de
véhicules tout-terrain indestructible
qui vient directement du futur qui n'est
pas fait une fois de plus pour monsieur
mais à tout le monde et l'idée
effectivement de caviar là dedans c'est
de prendre ces deux produits et de les
fusionner pour vous sortir un produit
vraiment très très très atypique et
c'est là qu'arrive le cas via iphone 11
pro seiver phone alors c'est un truc est
extrêmement perche est extrêmement
bizarre si vous le regardez si vous
faites vraiment vraiment gars c'est une
espèce de gros blocs version je dirais
sayler troc de tesla est un peu normal
vous allez l'ouvrir au niveau de l'écran
c'est là où ça devient un peu perso en
fait c'est à dire que votre smartphone
vous n'avez pas comme ça vous n'allez
pas pouvoir voir vos notifications non
il faut le prendre il faut l'ouvrir
donc il est protégé on est dans l'adn du
cider 3g' de tesla vous l'ouvrez vous
pouvez regarder pour ensuite leur poser
en dessous le poser pour regarder du
contenu à la verticale instagram
compagnie ci et ça vous pouvez le faire
ça vous permet également bien de
naviguer de travail est bon pourquoi pas
mais l'idée avant tout c'est de le
rendre votre smartphone indestructible
en tout cas extrêmement protégé alors
ici on parle pas dehors on parle pas de
diane son parle pas de tout ça ici on
parle de titane on parle de résistance
on parle de robustesse on va devenir
vraiment raconter cette histoire là bon
alors cet iphone 11 pro 11 promax on est
sur un iphone ils n'ont pas changé les
caractéristiques de l'iphone il faut
juste changer l'habillage
vous avez évidemment trois versions 64
giga de stockage 256 go de stockage ou
alors 512 et giga de stockage un châssis
comme je les ai fabriqués en titane
complètement anodisé un smartphone
numérotée s'est fait en toute petite
série a je pense que c'est vraiment des
produits qui sont faits main
qui explique aussi un peu le
positionnement tarifaire extrêmement il
n'y a pas d'industrie nations derrière
ça va être vendu en masse et vendu à
très très très très peu de personnes et
c'est aussi ce qui crée la valeur du
produit donc vous aurez votre produit
qui sera numérotée j'imagine qu'un
certificat d'authenticité comme sur tous
les produits luxe mais je vous le dis
une fois de plus on est réellement sur
une fiche technique d'iphone os 3 il
faut qu'on se profile
d'ailleurs s'ils voulaient en savoir
plus sur ces produits je vais aller voir
ma vidéo je sais pas si c'est là aussi
c'est là vous allez vous cliquer comme
ça vous saurez tout sur ses smartphones
bien évidemment nous ont oubliés avec un
joli packaging vous espèce de grosse
boîte à l'intérieur de la boîte une
autre boite c'est un peu les poupées
russes ans un peu l'idée qui va venir
abriter votre smartphone les accessoires
un produit d'exception nécessite un
packaging d'exception on n'aura pas une
expérience d'un boxing un peu standard
sur un iphone on aura un oeil boxing un
peu à part d'ailleurs si caviar vous
voulez me l'envoyer jeu bien réaliser le
doxie je crois que ça fait une
expérience un petit peu surprenante bien
évidemment tout ça un coup marquer là
dessus et c'est là que ça devient petit
peu rigolo nous ont mis juste un prix
sur leur site ils demandent de les
contacter pour avoir plus d'informations
le prix de base si vous regardez en non
car quand même un petit peu cher 14 1560
euros pour votre iphone
alors pour un iphone cider truck pour un
cyber phone pour un smartphone venu du
futur extrêmement résistant vous aurez
bien évidemment toutes les performances
de votre iphone dans introduit un petit
peu particulier oublié là dessus vous
n'aurez pas de recharge sans fil je ne
pense pas que ça fonctionne avec le
titane s'est pas non plus vous allez
venir rechercher un bon vieux
rechargement filaire qui va très vite
suffira et a parfaitement bien caviar
vous lâche pas dans la nature comme ça
disent ok ok produits en vous levant il
est cher quasiment quinze mille euros
on vous le garantit un an merci caviar
alors j'imagine que puisque caviar prend
votre smartphone le démon complètement
change tout la garantie apple je ne
pense pas qu'elle fonctionne derrière
donc la garantie kia byers est quand
même le grand minimum
voilà je voulais partager ça avec vous
on est un petit peu en dehors de ce
qu'on fait habituellement on n'est pas
sur un produit tech très grand public
fassi l'iphone c'est grand public mais
un iphone à quinze mille euros c'est
tout de suite un petit peu moins dites
moi ce que vous en pensez
comment vous trouvez déjà ce smartphone
apple tesla iphone 11 trop ans promax
seiver trucks comment vous trouvez une
mélange de ce que vous trouvez
intéressant est ce que c'est une cette
ligne de smartphones pourrait vous
intéresser à l'avenir et est ce que vous
pensez des constructeurs devraient
réfléchir pour nos frères des saveurs
phone version grand
vous marquez tout ça on dit comment vous
trouvez les smartphone le nokia 33-10 sa
version vladimir poutine
l'iphone mike tyson marilyn monroe
qu'est-ce qu'il vous faudrait que ça
c'est vraiment hâte de voir qu'est ce
que vous voudriez comme smartphone alors
me dites pas un iphone miss you re
customiser andorre avec duty talent et
puis vers son arme à feu prendre un
petit peu mal et le faire si james bond
ou tu vois comme ça ça serait un peu
dingue
dites moi ce que vous voudriez ambac
qu'est ce que vous pensez que caviar
devrait nous faire comme modèles propres
et pourquoi pas leur suggérer l'idée bar
qui m'a tout ça en bas en commentaire
quant à nous on se retrouve demain
quotidien par les tec la pelleteuse a
raconté
allez je vous envoie de l'amour à
bientôt le coeur
[Musique]